la suite du voyage de jacques chirac aux
antilles aujourd'hui le président de la
république en martinique a plaidé pour
un statut sur mesure pour chacun des
départements d'outre-mer estimant qu'il
fallait prendre en compte les
différences et les spécificités un
discours qui avait une résonance
particulière alors que l'on débatte du
statut de la corse pour sa part le maire
de fort de france haute figure politique
locale n'a pas hésité à faire l'amalgamé
entre la revendication corse et la
nécessité de l'autonomie des antilles
reportage véronique synthé livre jean
paul chaussée
autonomie un peu beaucoup passionnément
les antilles revendique aujourd'hui un
nouveau statut ici les élus toutes
étiquettes confondues déclare bruce de
pouvoir pour gérer sont toujours passer
par paris leurs institutions et leur
développement économique et c'est aimé
césaire 87 ans poète et sage qui met les
points sur les i
ce qui est important c'est qu'on
reconnaît qu'il ya un peu précoce qui a
pourtant manqué et nous nous sommes
regroupés dans une formule qui nous
permet d'être nous-mêmes ce n'est fini
le temps de l'aliénation les élus
domiens ont jusqu'au 18 mars pour faire
leurs propositions avant que jean-jack
queyranne le ministre des dom-tom
défendent à l'assemblée nationale le
projet de loi du gouvernement de son
côté jacques chirac espère en venant ici
reprend à son compte toutes les
aspirations d'accord avec lionel jospin
sur le principe de l'autonomie le
président de la république se démarque
en plaidant par exemple pour la
défiscalisation mais le chef de l'état
veut surtout se poser en arbitres et
fixer le cadre du débat institutionnel
aucune de ces démarches ne me gêne
aucune de ces approches ne me choque ma
conviction
est que les statuts uniforme ont vécu et
que chaque collectivité d'outre-mer doit
pouvoir désormais si elle le souhaite
évoluer vers un statut différencier en
quelque sorte un statut sur mesure les
départements et les territoires
d'outre-mer ont toujours représenté une
réserve de voix importantes qui peuvent
faire la différence lors d'une élection
présidentielle
aujourd'hui jacques chirac comme lionel
jospin savent donc qu'ils doivent
convaincre ces français du bout du monde
qu'ils s'occupent de leurs intérêts et
de leur avenir et c'est à qui fera le
mieux passer son message